はい よろしくお願いします
あの できるだけ大きい声で喋りますけど
もし聞き取れなかったならば少々言ってください
あの 今日のテーマは誘惑の正体
仏教徒にとっての悪魔とはということで
紹介する文章にもあったように
大体宗教の歴史には悪魔っていうのはつきまとうものなんです
で まあ早くテーマに入りますから
あまりあの...回り道をなく
まあ悪魔 宗教の場合は邪魔なものか大事なものか
ちょっとわからないというところもありますけど
ドストエフスキーが書いた話には逆を書いてますけど
ある あの 誰でしたっけ？すごい敬虔な信仰深い神父様がいて
あの各家を訪ねて 各村を訪ねて
一生懸命この悪魔退治をするんです
なかなか大変な人で であるどこかにこの悪魔に囚われていたという家に行って
まあ一生懸命お祈りをして悪魔退治して
まあロシアだからね まあまあ冬でしたし
この人はまあ真夜中帰ってくるんですね
一人で長い道を そうすると
この雪の中に 雪の道路そばで
雪の中で誰が倒れてるんですね
あの...もう後ろ向きにというか
まあ顔は見えない 背中は見えます
そこら辺はものすごい白い雪の上で血が流れている
また すごくもう泣いているんです
痛くて 神父さんが親切な人だから
あ これ大変だ これは大変だ
この人を助けなくちゃ
で 繰り返して見たんです
まあ顔は顔の方 まあどうせそちらに変わらなくちゃいけないんだからね
そしたらなんだ もうこれ悪魔そのその本人なんですね
尾っぽも付いているのです
いきなり自分がずっと悪魔退治しているんだからね
まあなんかちょっと下がったんですね
下がったら悪魔がこう言うんです
まあ私も私を助けてくれと
あの 何でしたっけ？悪魔と戦う天使が
アントニ？え？ミカエル
あのミカエル野郎にくたびれやられて殺されそうになったと
とんでもないやつやと
というと 神父さんが怒鳴るんです
お前が悪しきものだからね
ミカエルがやった善人がやったことは正しいんだと
死んだ方が間違と 助けてあげませんと
そしたら悪魔が ああそう
そう思ってるんですかねと
もし私がここで死んだら
世の中で悪がなくなりますよと
誰も悪いことしなくなっちゃいますよと
というと あんたどうするんですか？と
あんたの教会やらね 全部いらなくなっちゃいますよと
あなたの商売全部上がりますよと
教会の 結局あなた方は私のおかげで食べているのではないかと
じゃあ死ぬようにして置いておきなさいと
それで神父さんはよく考えたんで
やっぱりこいつがないと商売にならないんだと
それであの悪魔を背負って
あの まあ小説ですから
小説だって小さな物語が美しく書いてますよ
神父さんがね 頭 髪の毛からもう手のつのの先まで血がポロポロポロポロ
もう悪魔の血なんですね
もうもう落ちながら もう一生懸命ね
長い道のりを重い悪魔を背負って
まあ教会に戻ったと ということで
だからまあ想像的には神父さんの白い服は全部血に染まったってことなんです
悪魔助けをして まあそれがまあもう本当に小説家
あの神話ね 人間のこのいろいろ物語をね
美しく書いているところで
やっぱり小説家だから言いたいところは
やっぱりこれもうややこしいということなんです
悪魔がなくとは 敵じゃなくてなくてはならない存在になっています
悪魔に誘惑されて人は罪を犯しているということ
悪いのは悪魔ですね 私ではありません
人は残酷な独裁者に徹底的に束縛されて支配されているような気持ちでいるようです
だからまあ徹底的に悪魔にやられているんだから
もうまあ知らんという
なんか無気力状態を表しているんですね
自分 悪魔に誘惑されると自分が無罪なのに
それに気づかないのはなぜでしょうかと
だから悪魔を導入して
何が人間に言いたいかった
言いたいかというと これ
悪魔に誘惑されて悪いことしてるんだと
悪魔さえなければもう大変いい人間でいるんだよと言いたいんですね
もし悪魔に誘惑されて
支配されて 抑えられて
脅かされて罪を犯しているならば
もう常識では自分が無罪なんですよ
だから我は無罪であると胸を張っていればいいのに
なんかどうかわからないんですけど
人間がまた落ち込んで悩んでるんですね
自分が無罪っていうことに気づかないのは何なのかということ
私が疑問に思っています
あるいは味方ではなければ
だからなぜ味方かというタイトルを書いたかというと
時々このアホな親が子供をしつけしないで
いいお父さんが悪かった
お母さんが悪かったとか
自分が悪者になるんです
子供が万引きしたら それはお母さんが悪かった
お父さんが悪かった それって悪魔な悪魔の役なんですね
子供の味方になってやるぞと
それで子供は永久的にだらしない人間になるんです
期待通りに 私 すっごく気持ち悪くなるんですよ
もう親がね お父さん悪かったとかね
お母さんが悪かったとか言うと
で そういう役柄を演じさせてますね
悪魔にも だから両親が子供の味方ですからね
悪魔は味方でしょうかと
あるいは逆な言葉で悪魔というのは寂しいですかと
なぜかというと 甘い言葉で人を罪に誘惑するという解釈もありますね
悪魔っていうのは随分甘い言葉かけてくれるんだと
パーリ聖典にもナムチカルナワーチャンムパーガミというナムチさんがものすごい甘い言葉を言いながら私のところに来たんだよと
お釈迦様がこの悟る前に菩薩の時は
来たんだっていう風にあります
だから甘い言葉言って人を騙して罪を犯させるならば
えらい詐欺師なんですね
そうすると善行を行いなさいという神が恐ろしい言葉で人を脅し
罰を与える悪い存在になる
悪魔が優しい言葉で ものすごく優しい言葉で語るならば
悪魔の反対は神だから
神が恐ろしい言葉で 脅しの言葉でものすごく人を侮辱
脅さなくちゃいけないんですよ
罰を与えてやるぞとか
あれこれと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから言葉荒っぽくなっちゃうんです
そうなってくると 神様の
それだったら誰も神様のところに行かなくなっちゃいますね
性格悪いんだから 自分が創造した命なので
誘惑されやすい生き方に対して神に責任があるんです
だから神と悪魔っていうのはセットですから
あの神が創造したんだから
創造したものはすごい簡単に誘惑される
神の言葉を聞かないならば
責任は神にあるんです
ですから 全部あの生命の人間の罪が
もう神様が自分で償わなくちゃいけないんです
人間は罪人で亡くなっちゃいます
だから悪魔がもう詐欺師やと思ったっても
結局人間は無罪ということになるんです
これって結局は責任逃れということなんです
悪いのは私ではなく あの人だという
と人間が言いたいんです
自分で悪いことしながら
いつでも心の中で悪いのは私じゃないんだと
それ言いたいんですよ
自分の行為に責任を持ちたくないのは
持ちたくはないのです
一般的なこの変な神話を置いておいて
人間の生き方を見ると
人間っていうのは好き勝手に生きているんですけど
自分の行為に対して責任を持ちたくはないんです
だから誰かのせいにする
他人に指をさして自分が落ち着くでしょうという考えですね
それで自分が悪いことをすると
すごく気持ち悪いんですよ
それから失敗したり 不幸になったり
苦しみに陥ったりすると
かっこ悪いんです なので
これはもう悪魔のせい
社会のせい 家族のせい
親のしつけのせいと 学校の仲間のせいとか
なんとか誰かのせいにして自分が落ち着くと自己嫌悪に陥らないと思っているんです
真面目にそのように思っても
自分に対して自己嫌悪になることは避けられない
結局は自己嫌悪に陥りたくないという目的で
もう他人にもう自分の行為の責任を投げるんです
私じゃない 人のせいだとと言っただけで
精神的に安らぎになりますかね
ならないんです それでも
特にこの現代社会ではね
まあ精神的にイカれてる人っていうのはものすごいたくさんいるんですね
もう５０％以上ぐらい
今失敗していますよ 仕事をあることできないは
勉強をあることにしない
しなかったし で もう人間となかなかうまく付き合うことはできないし
そういういろんな問題があったりして
それで勉強できなかったことも他人のせい
仕事に行きたくないのも他人のせい
仕事を失敗するのも他人のせい
大人になっても家で引きこもっているのも他人のせい
親のせい 会社のせいと言うんです
30歳になっていても
35歳になってももう引きこもっている場合いるんですよ
理由は？理由を聞いたら
これ親のせいか社会の自分が正しいんです
いつでも そんなに正しければ
堂々と胸を張っていればいいでしょうに
そうじゃないんです ものすごく落ち込んで苦しんでいるんです
それでも他人の責任をせいにしようとは人間するんです
だから便利な とても便利な考えですよ
悪魔っていうのは だから悪魔っていうのは人間が作ったんです
悪魔という神 神という神は人間が作ったんです
人間の無知の屁理屈の妄想の産物です
それで人間作ったものだから
神と悪魔の関係は何なのかというと
神の概念を作ると悪魔の概念も必要です
世界は苦に満ちていて
希望通りにならない そういう理由なんです
まあ全知全能の完全たる神がこの森羅万象を作ったんだよと
何か文句あるのかといえば
それで話は終わりますけど
事実見ないで妄想で語ってるんだから
しかし この言ってる精神異常者も
人間と一緒に生活しなきゃいけないんですよ
この預言者という人も
そう 自分のことも自分も不完全でろくでもない人生で
だいたい預言者っていうのは社会から追い出されて
もうもうなんか病人扱いされて非難を受けたりして
ろくでもない人間ですから
ほとんどの場合は だから自分の人生ももうろくなものじゃない
人間の自分と一緒に生活している人々もすごい苦しんで
例えばこのユダヤ教のね
それっていうのはエジプトで書き出したものでしょ
旧約聖書は ユダヤ人がエジプトで奴隷でいたんですね
その何の独立性もなく
長い間奴隷にされちゃって
殺されたり ひどい目に遭わせられ
それからものすごいひどい目に遭わされていて
それでまた完全たる神のことを妄想
妄想するんだから まあ相当頭がね
おかしいんですよ それですぐ事実見えますね
世界は苦に満ちているということ
希望通りにいかないということ
それで神様と一緒に悪魔も作らなくちゃいけなくなるんです
悪いのは悪魔だよと 理屈はないんです
そんな変なことを 論理ないということは
そういう神話物語を作った人々はちょっと精神的な問題があったということなんです
神話は普通に作れますよ
イソップ物語とかね 神話ものがいっぱいありますよ
理屈通ってます いくらなんでも
シンデレラ物語にしても
ちゃんと理屈は通ってますよ
でなきゃ成り立ちませんだから
それで悪魔もいるんだと言ったら
いきなりもう悪魔は誰が作ったっていうことの問題で出てくるし
何で作ったのかとかね
神様が困ってるんだと
悪魔のことで だったら早く処分し
いいのに 問題ははっきり見ているのに解決しないということは
その代わりなんで人間に当たるんでしょうかと
雷を落としたり 洪水を作ったり
伝染病そういう聖書に書いてるもので
伝染病にさせたりとか
何やってるんですかね
問題ははっきり自分で知ってるのに
それってけしからんですよ
だからなんでそういうふうに理屈が成り立たないストーリーを作るのかって
やっぱりもうまああんまり頭がいいってことじゃないんです
神が不完全だとも言えないんですね
いくらなんでも 神の概念を作る人々に
神ってだらしないんだととは言いたくはないんです
そういうわけで 悪魔が必要になるんです
したがって 悪いことはすべて悪魔のせいにする
神と悪魔が野党と与党のようであるならば面白いし
そうじゃないんですよ
もし私がそういう創造論のストーリーを作ったならば
これを野党と与党にしておくんです
しかし あの与党はあくまで野党は神様にするんですけど
それでは民主主義によって誰を選んでも構わないことになるんです
神を選んだら 生きている上ではひどい惨めで生きていて
もう約束だけ 天国に天国に行けると
これわからない で 悪魔を選んだら
毎日楽しく人間と仲良くして
まあ頑張って生きていられると
まあどちらか民主主義で選べばいいということになります
でも残念ながら この神と悪魔っていうのは与党と野党ではないんですね
なんか政府と反逆者という感じで考えているんです
反逆者が捕まっているならば処分すればいいでしょうに